>> Alright so we're back in again, and we're going to attack it I the way
that we, that you attacked the previous ones,
where we're going to ask, kind of systematically is the
VC dimension, greater than or equal to 1, 2, 3, 4 by, by giving examples until
we just can't anymore [LAUGH]. So good, so
is the VC greater than or equal to one?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. So, what would that mean? All we need to do is provide
a point, I don't know, call it the origin. And.
>> Basically, we get to just pretend that it's like a single point on a line
with a VC dimension of one and it,
the same argument that we had before, applies.
>> That's a good way to say it. Just you know, just think about the
x asis, axis itself, and we can label
something, well actually it's simpler in a sense
because, we can keep the line steady and we can just flip which side is, you
know, by negating all the weights we can
flip which side is positive and which side
is negative, and that gives us the 2 labelings of that point.
>> Right, and because similar argument for VC of 2.
>> So, if the 2 points were on a
line, then to do the 4 different combinations, we could.
>> So right, by putting that line to the left, we
can label both of them positive. That's easy, or we could label
both of them negative by flipping the weights. Now we've to do
the other 2 cases where they've different labels. So, I'm going to recommend
putting a blue line between them.
>> It's a thin blue line.
>> [LAUGH] Yes, and you know, the one on the right is positive the one
on the left is negative, or we can flip the weights and then flip the signs.
>> Yes, and 3 is where we got into trouble
last time, so let's let me start off by giving ourselves
a clean slate. So, this ran us into trouble in the
case of the intervals because we couldn't do that case and
it looks like we're kind of hosed again, right?
>> Yeah, we're. We're actually completely hosed again, if we do this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, I'm going to say that the
problem is not with the hypothesis space. The problem
is with the hand that is drawing points
on the screen. So that's you, so here's the.
>> My hand is really depressed.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [SOUND]
>> Well, I'm going to make your hand happier. So, I think
it's right that you can't separate this. It's, and,
and the reason you can't separate it's because we've
3 points on the number line and there's just
sort of nothing to do here, just like we'd before.
But, we are not restricted to the number line.
So I'm going to recommend cheating, and moving that
point in the middle off the number line. So
make a triangle, stick it up in the middle somewhere.
>> Alright, and that gives us the ability to handle
this case now, because we can just send our slicey line
this way. Put everything below it as
positive and everything above it as negative.
>> Right, now of course we still, by doing that
we might have messed up the other labeling, so we
should check to make certain that we haven't we haven't
screwed anything up. So, we can, we can make the
top minus and the bottom, plus that's true and we
can just by flipping the weights we can make it
the top plus and the bottom minus right? So that's
good. And the question is that can we do anything else.
>> Yeah, I think it's pretty clear. We could definitely label them all
positive or all negative just by putting
a vertical line somewhere off to the left.
>> Yeah, and I think it's actually easier than this because if you just
think about vertical lines, then we really are back in the one dimensional case.
>> Right. And, and we handled the other 7 cases in the
one dimmensional case really easily. It was just this, this extra case
that we didn't know how to do and now we do, we
just use that 3rd dimmension. [LAUGH] Or the 2nd dimmension, even better.
>> [LAUGH]
Fair enough. Okay, so the answer's yes. I feel good about that. Okay, so, that's
good. So we got, we got 1, 2, and 3 out of the way, so
we know it's more powerful. We know
that it's better. This's, this's kind of nice. So
now the question is 4. So, thinking about it, I think that the answer is no.
>> [LAUGH] That would be nice, wouldn't it? But, no, we need a, we
need a slightly better argument and I think, I think we can do that,
what we need. Again, what would be helpful
is if we had an example, where we could
say, okay, here's a labeling that no matter how
you lay out the points, you're going to fail.
>> So, in order for that to work, we need to try to use
all the power of the 2 dimensions so we don't fall in a trap. Right
if, like we almost did with VC3 by making them collinear. So, why don't you
place 4 points in the plane and make a kind of like a diamond shape,
or a square, which is like a diamond.
>> It's a diamond shape if you yeah, tilt your head a little bit.
>> Okay, so I'm going to tilt my head to look at it. So, here's
my argument. Now, I don't know if this's quite right Michael, so, so help me
out with it. The reason I don't think you can do 4 is because we've only got
lines to work with. Okay so, if you connect all the points [CROSSTALK]
>> Hm-mm.
>> All, all pairs of points the way they,
all ways they can be connected. So, you know,
draw the square on the outside and then draw the 2 [CROSSTALK]
>> Hm-mm.
>> Cross ones in the middle. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, it makes sense, but I'm not sure where we're going with this.
>> Okay, so I'm not either so [LAUGH] so, so, so work with
me. So that's kind of all the boundaries that you can imagine drawing.
And the problem that I see here is that because of the way
that the, the 2 lines that the x and the interior of the square's
set up. There's kind of no way to label the
ones on the other side of those lines differently without
crossing them. So that made no sense what I said,
right? So, try putting the, a plus in the upper left
and bottom right. And minus for the other 2. So,
if you look at the, the 2 1's that are
connected by the line with the plus, and the 2
1s that are connected by the minus, they cross each other,
right? There's no way to put a single line that will
allow you to separate out the pluses from the minuses here.
>> Yeah, yeah. Exactly. So, in particular anything
that puts, these 2 pluses on the same
side is either going to put one minus or the other minus on that same side.
>> Right.
>> It has a very XOR kind of feeling to it, to me.
>> Yeah does, it, it,it does and in fact
it has an x right there in the middle.
>> [LAUGH] It does, no but it, that is true,
but I meant it in a slightly different way, which is if you think
about these 4 points as actually being you know, zero, zero. 1-1, 0-1 and 1-0.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then, the labeling here is exactly XOR. And XOR is one of these things
that you can't capture with a linear seperator. So I think, I think you got it.
>> Oh, it makes sense. And I think the important thing here, is that oh
I like the XOR argument. The important thing here is that, no matter where I
move those four points, I can take the one closer or
one further away. And I could, they're no longer squares, but
whatever I want to be, they're always, you're always going to have
a structure where you can draw those kind of crosses between
the 4 points. Or, you're going to end up collapsing the points
on top of one another or making 3 of them co-linear
or all four of them co-linear and so that makes it
even harder to do any kind of separation. Cause now we're back.
>> Right. You fail
on all the, but there, there's one case that
I'm not sure that you quite described yet. Like that.
>> Right. Well, I think that, that works out to be the same thing, right?
If you draw the connecting lines together they're
all going to cross at the middle point.
>> There's no crossings.
>> They all cross at that point. They all meet at that point.
>> They don't cross at that point.
>> Well, so those are line segments, but those are just
line segments they represent lines that go on forever. Good point.
>> Yeah so, but the way,
the way that I would see this one is, again to just give an example of a
labeling that just can't be separated would be
this one. Like if you capture the outside points,
assigning all the outside points one label, you
can't assign the input, the inside points a different
label. It's inside the convex hall, it's going
to have the same label as the other ones.
>> Exactly. So, the, and I, and well so in my head the, the main issue
is as lines, when lines cross there's really
nothing you can do with a single line.
Never cross the streams.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah. It still doesn't feel like quite the same.
I mean maybe we're belaboring this point. Here in this square,
if you actually let this, this corner point pushed into the
middle, then we can, I think we can linearly separate them.
>> Sure.
>> So, I feel like these are 2 different cases,
but regardless the point is, that what we, what we argued
is no matter how you lay out the points, there's
always going to be a labeling that can't be achieved in
the hypothesis class.
>> Yeah, the whole crossing of the lines thing, really is
about being able to get all 4 points. It's not saying that
any pair of points. Works out okay. So, what you'd end
up doing is taking one of those points and dragging them into
the middle, and then the lines all meet like in, in
what you've drawn. And you end up with the basically the, the
same argument. I think it's the same thing. But, I do agree
with one thing, Michael. Which is that we are belaboring this point.
>> Because the good news or the, the exciting news
is no, we really argued that the
VC dimension of linear separators is not greater
than or equal to four. So therefore, it's 3. Because 3 works and 4 doesn't.
>> And 3 is my favorite number. So, I have a question for you
Michael, I noticed that we keep getting in all the examples we have done so
far, we keep getting one more VC dimension, so does this kind of argument work
if I went from planes to, or let's see, 2D space or 3D space or
4D space or 5D space? is the VC
dimension still three or does it keep getting bigger?